>> Welcome everyone to
this session on the
good bad and the ugly
of ML in network systems.
Applying ML to a problem needs
no real motivation
or push in 2018.
We're seeing a huge surge
in developing
ML techniques for a lot of
large-scale network systems.
With the huge amount
of data and computing
power available,
this actually makes
it quite feasible.
Of course, Microsoft has been in
the forefront of applying
data at huge scales to
large-scale systems issues.
However, there is
a growing voice,
maybe even the silent majority of
voices in the systems and
networking community,
that is clamoring for
more principal solutions.
They're concerned
that they're building
solutions without
quite understanding
what they actually do.
This session intends to
write into this to stop.
What are the network systems
for which ML is appropriate?
The fact that we have built
systems are built
with abstractions,
does it make it more amenable to
using black-box
ML-based techniques?
Finally, do we even need
full understanding of
the solutions as the so-called
traditionalists insist?
To discuss all these
questions and more,
we have a panel of
researchers in this space.
We'll start with Balaji
Prabhakar from Stanford.
Balaji is a professor
at Stanford.
His research is largely in
the space of
self-programming networks,
particularly in the context of
cloud computing platforms
and data centers.
Balaji has a long list
of awards but I won't
list all of them but I would
just note that is one,
the Erlang prize from
the Applied Probability Society,
and the Rollo Davidson Prize
from the University of Cambridge.
He's a Sloan fellow,
Itripoli and ACM fellow as well.
>> Thank you. Hi, good
afternoon everybody.
I'm going to take a position
and my main thesis is that,
on the good bad ugly side,
I'm going to say it's good.
What's ugly and sometimes
can be bad is the hype,
but in of themselves,
there's nothing wrong with ideas,
is how we end up
using them or worse,
how we end up making
a bigger dealer of them.
So, some of my background
is theoretical,
and so the scientific
modelling process
always goes on a knife edge.
There are few theorems
that give universality,
but other than that,
things tend to be
for tractability.
We make some models and
they work by and large.
There's some well-known
combinations,
like linear systems go with
Gaussian noise really well,
and that goes with quadratic
cost functions really well.
That's a fairly large amount
of optimal control theory,
stochastic control, runs on
those three assumptions.
People have tried relaxing
any one of these and
it's not been easy.
Nobody's heard from those people
who've tried to relax
these assumptions.
They've gone off into
the woods and never come back.
Similarly, networking
we know there is again
Markovian assumption
whether it's to poisson
arrivals and exponential
services small variations but,
otherwise, by and large,
that's a successful
modeling class.
What happens when we
leave this world of
modeling assumptions
don't quite work
or not want to capture
something in more exact detail?
That is where lots of
data in these days,
and when combined with
neural networks and
ML, can actually help.
So, it helps us to capture
something that is actual,
an actual system where
the modeling assumptions
have gone some distance,
but now, we want to be
more exact than that.
What that does is it
does certainly leave
the burden of
understanding upon us,
and I'm okay if
first we get success
in that understanding,
usually prefers
understanding first,
and then success, then we can
declare success correctly.
But people have had
observations that for which
theories will come
later, that's fine.
It's what just saying sharing
an anecdote with Niels Bohr,
about Niels Bohr
or involving him.
He had a scientific
friend visit with
him at some summer home
that he had in
the mountains somewhere,
and banged on the door
frame of his house.
There was horseshoe,
which is well-known
as a good luck charm.
So, scientific friend
said, "Surely,
Professor Bohr, you don't
believe in this superstition."
He said, "Well, I
don't believe in it,
but they say it works,
whether you believe
in it or not."
It's not a bad thing
to keep in mind
for the topic of this panel.
I want to take two specific uses
for neural networks.
First this so-called
function approximation.
The well known to
have the property
of approximating functions.
A two layer neural
networks are universal
as long ago theorem
of Andrew Barons.
Second is that, when combined
with hardware of the GPU,
TPU type, this ability
to approximate a function
can vastly speed up,
and was very useful
for us in networking.
Speed up computations,
I'm going to give
you some examples.
One example supporting both
is from self-programming
networks.
So, I'll tell you what that is,
and briefly also tell
you some work I've
been doing with the
students Sachin Katti,
Mani Kotaru, and also
Gordon Wetzstein
who's a colleague who specialize
in VR computer vision.
Finally, I was at
the Simons Institute Program
in Berkeley last season,
last spring in the one
that is run by,
and we had a physicist from
Caltech who's involved in
elementary particle physics,
this large hadron collider,
and they also use neural networks
and pretty much the same way
that I'm going
to describe it for
the same reasons also.
So, self-programming networks as
a research program on Stanford,
Mendel Rosenblum and I are
working on it together
with a bunch of students,
and the infrared learners are
blue because that's where
we've used some neural networks.
So, again, what is self-driving,
self-programming networks.
So, think of a self-driving car,
you take a plain old car.
If you add sense
and control to it,
then it becomes Stanley
the self-driving car,
this is Sebastian thrown the
on the trunk under the hood.
Similarly, we would take
a plain old data center,
and our focus is on data centers.
So, in other words,
I'm not advocating
what we're doing for
wider Internet yet because
there's some particular
assumptions we made.
You have sense and control to it,
and we want to use that
to form a self-programming
networks.
I don't have time
to tell you more
about it, where we sense,
how we control, its mostly
is NIC-based approach.
What that allows us to do is
to run some new applications that
can run on the old
plain old data centers,
that allows us to run this
because it has
additional functionality,
like very accurate timestamping
service and so on.
So, in this wall,
neural networks, I
want to get to it.
Comes in the following
way: We've taken
a thermography type approach
to measurement.
I look at ingress and egress
times of packets at NICs.
When you have this for
a whole bunch of packets,
you're in the world of solving
simultaneous linear equations to
determine from the total time
how much time was
spent in each box.
The algorithm for this is
LASSO, the one we use.
So, you're looking
at the total delay,
D. A is the adjacency matrix
that decides what path
the packet took,
Q is the queuing delays
of the switches its
visiting, N is the noise.
Noise is variable wireless,
NIC timestamping inaccuracy,
various things like this.
We worked on this and tested
it in Google's 40G-test bed,
the internal production network
and various other places,
our Internet data
center at Stanford,
but this is the algorithm.
So, given the end-to-end delay,
estimate individual queuing
delays or a certain interval.
This works, but with
slow LASSO algorithm scales
poorly with the size
of the network.
There are faster implementations
of LASSO but even so,
we want to see if we can just
teach a neural
network to do this.
What that means is, take
an algorithm like LASSO,
it has it's input
output map that defines
a function and take
the input-output pairs,
lots and lots and lots of them,
and train a neural
network with it.
You have to remember after all,
we're just inverting noisy
in linear equations.
If there's no noise in
that equation well-determined,
it was just another
linear system.
So, you expect a
priori the Neural Networks
should have a good chance.
So, it turns out just a two layer
is completely as
shallow as you can get,
a Neural Network of the basic
ReLU type is good enough.
So, what's the result look like?
On the top is
Reconstruction Accuracy.
This first chart.
You can have different
size networks.
LASSO has a root-mean-squared
error which is,
you can think of it as how
many packets like roughly three
full-sized for
general byte packets
roughly, that's the error.
The second column is
Neural Networks trained
with ground truth when
you have it available.
Third is to
Neural Network trained
with the output of LASSO itself.
So, as you can see,
it's pretty accurate but it
is not much loss of accuracy.
But the killer is
the second thing.
LASSO scales poorly
as I said before,
30 milliseconds worth of
data takes you more
than a millisecond,
depending on size
of the network, you
can get as bad as a second.
But if we're trying
Neural Network,
we can still be tracking time.
So, that's an example
of function
approximation capability
as well as hardware acceleration.
So, that's my first example.
Second one is again,
very briefly even
briefer than this is,
work with Mani Kotaru,
who's Sachin's student as I said.
Sachin and his students
have had a theme
of using Wi-Fi signals
for various things,
in this case is localization.
There's a VR headset
that's moving,
Wi-Fi signals are captured.
The goal is to localize
based on the signals.
There's a well-known
mid-seventies algorithm
called Music that does it.
It cancels the indirect path,
etcetera, it does.
But it had a 60-centimeter error,
when music does the localization.
In work that took money more
than a year and a
half because you
really it's not like
off the shelf ML,
it's like you have
work, wrestled with it.
I actually thought he
won't even succeed,
maybe there's not
an easy function to
approximate, but he did.
There's a submission
on this it's,
four-centimetre error and it's
also really fast by
comparison with Music.
So, this example
is second example,
and the last one is just,
I'm going to- I really
encourage you to read
it because I was quite
impressed with the way the
physics folks are doing it.
This is from CERN.
I'm happy to share this with
folks who beyond the URL.
So basically, what happens in
the Large Hadron Collider,
it has got some
elementary particles,
something is held over here
and something really fast comes
and bangs it and then
stuff like muons,
gluons, all these guys come out,
and then they traced
the trajectory of
these particles,
that's their business.
But the data generated is so
huge that they had to sensor it,
they can't store everything.
The article starts by
saying, in the 60's,
people used to pore over
these images and reconstruct
the trajectory is to
find out if they're
found a new elementary
particle and
modeling the Higgs Boson type
things showing up or not.
Then the learning revolution
has just begun and
it was based on
grid computing that was
introduced in the 2000's.
What they're now doing is just,
it's exactly reconstruction.
So, my problem of the inverse,
given the overall
delay find me the
queue sizes that's called
an inverse problem,
that is a forward equation
is D equals AQ plus N,
the inverse equation
is given D find NQ.
There's another inverse problem,
inverse problems are in MRI.
All of those are inverse problems
and there's another
inverse problem and
the most recent work
has been about training
this neural networks to just
do the inverse problems
and find the trajectories.
So, what the equivalent
of LASSO for them is
the classical quantum
mechanics laws
and then they restrain them.
I think it's harder acceleration
plus all that is
beneficially used in
this case as well. So,
with that I'll stop.
>> The format we're
hoping is that,
if there are any burning
questions one or two we
could bring it up now but if
you have more broader questions,
we ask that you keep it
for the panel at the end.
Any quick questions while
Bruce gets setup. Okay.
We'll try my laptop.
Yes, while Bruce get set up.
Bruce is from Duke University.
His interests are in
large-scale networks as
well as his research.
Prior to that Bruce was at
Carnegie Mellon University
where he helped launch
the Akamai CDN Service
and he was the first
vice president of research and
development for Akamai
where he continues to
hold a role as
vice president for research.
Bruce's work has won
the SIGCOMM Networking
Systems Award,
as well as the IEEE
Cybersecurity Innovation Award.
>> We're going to go with VGA.
>> Got it hooked hooked up there?
>> Yes.
>> There you go.
>> Thank you Ganesh.
It's nice to be here,
I have to say that I am giving
this presentation with
some trepidation,
because I don't really use
ML very much in my work.
I tried to think of
the best justification
I could find for myself
as a speaker and it occurred to
me that I have ML
in my middle name.
So, I'm a traditional
systems designer.
I like to design big systems,
the biggest example
is the "Akamai CDN",
large parts of which I designed.
I like to try to
optimize these systems,
and I like to fix them.
One of the things I've discovered
over and over is that whenever
you take measurements and
look at how your
system's performing,
you find out that it's broken,
broken either not
functioning correctly,
or it's just performing
very poorly.
There's a methodology
that I've used
many times to try to
either improve systems,
or design systems with
new capabilities,
that I call data-driven design
of network systems.
So, the idea is that,
you look around for
existing systems that are
already deployed
on a large scale,
and from which you can
collect a lot of data,
possibly data of different types,
and then you think about,
how could we marry
these datasets,
to help us evaluate
new system designs?
Maybe for a system that
does something different,
or that does the same thing
but in a very different way.
So, one example of this,
maybe the first one I
was involved in was,
there was a new system
that had been developed at
Carnegie Mellon around 2000 or
so for purely
peer-to-peer delivery
of live or real-time video
called N System Multicast.
This was not my work,
it was Wei Jiang, and Saddy Raul,
and several others, they won
the Sigmetrics Test of time award
for their paper describing
N System Multicast.
But, they didn't have
a very good way of
evaluating whether or
not this system could
really hold up under
real workloads.
So, one of the things we did was,
we gathered all the logs from
Akamai real-time
video delivery system,
then we used that to drive
simulations of ESM
and the kinds of
questions we were
interested in were, well,
when there's
a massive flash crowd at
the beginning of
some scheduled event,
and peers are joining
and leaving rapidly,
is the system stable?
Most of the time, we
found that in fact,
even without the
dedicated infrastructure,
that Akamai had deployed
for its real-time
streaming network,
the ESM was still
mostly successful.
Let me give you another
example of this kind of work.
So, here's a fact that
maybe people don't know,
but TLS certificate
revocation checking
is broken in a bad way,
and here's how.
Your mobile device doesn't
check for certificate revocation.
So, what this means is,
if you go to
some website where you
provide your password,
and maybe use the same password
at a lot of websites,
and somebody has stolen that
site's private key somehow.
Maybe through a bug,
like the Heartbleed bug,
and somehow they have
interfered with DNS and you've
gone to an imposter site,
and despite the fact
that the true owner of
that certificate has reported
it as no longer valid,
and put it on a revocation list,
your device will
not check for that.
I know this because I've tested
all the mobile devices,
Android devices, iPhones.
I couldn't find any example
in which any device
ever checked for
certificate revocation.
The reason they don't is
that it's too expensive.
One of the things
I found a little
frustrating this morning going to
talks about formally verifying
security properties,
making sure your
implementations of
the protocols are
correct and so on,
is that there are
these other economic reasons
why whole parts of the protocol
just aren't implemented.
So, on mobile devices,
they don't do certificate
revocation checking because it
will be too much
bandwidth to download
the whole list of
revoked certificates.
Or, it would take
too long to contact
an OCSP server to ask is
this certificate valid.
Or, there's new protocols
like OCSP stapling,
but only two or three percent of
servers are supporting that.
So, It's just not done,
and this is a crying shame.
So, we started thinking about,
is there data out
there that would make
it possible to
solve this problem?
It is not difficult to find
the list of all the
revoked certificates,
because they're on
the certificate revocation list.
But what's harder to find is,
a list of all the valid
certificates, until recently,
when Google was so annoyed
that semantic had made
some fake certificates,
that they launched something
called certificate transparency,
and now, they
basically pressuring
certificate authorities,
to put into, just to
spice up my talk,
I'm going to say
a blockchain type of log,
every certificate
that they issue.
In addition to that, there's
some research projects
that have been going around,
scanning the whole
IPv4 address space,
pulling every certificate
they can from port 443.
So, suddenly we have
a new dataset we didn't
have before which is,
all the valid certificates.
So, we had the invalid
ones before,
and now we have the valid ones.
By the way, it's a lot
of certificates.
We're talking about
tens of millions.
This suggests a way
to represent in
a very compact data structure,
complete information
about every certificate
indicating whether it's
been revoked or not.
The structure is called
a "Filter Cascade".
So, the idea is that,
you take all the
revoked certificates,
and you insert them
into a "Bloom Filter".
Now, that would be
fine as a solution
except that it'd be really
unfair if there was
a false positive,
and some websites certificate
is now marked as
revoked because there was
just a bad collision.
So, then you take all the
non-revoked certificates,
and you ask, "Are there
any false positives?"
For all the false positives,
you create a "Bloom
Filter" to hold those.
There are a lot more non
revoked certificates
than revoked.
So, that it's important
that the first
level you insert
the revoked ones,
so you can have a small table,
but with a really small
false positive rate.
Then you say, "What about
revoked certificates
that accidentally
get marked as false positives,
meaning they would
be considered as
non revoked you
make it a little?"
So, you get this
geometric decrease,
and it turns out that
this "Filter Cascade",
it has 43 levels,
but you only expect to do
ten hashes to look up
the status of any certificate,
and the whole thing,
only takes 1.1 megabytes to
represent the precise status
of every certificate.
There's a lower bound,
an information theoretic lower
bound of 0.77 megabytes,
so you're not going
to do much better.
So basically,
today there are
60 million valid certificates,
that number is
about 40 million higher
than it was two years ago.
Maybe 50 million, because
of Let's Encrypt.
Today, in September we had
850 thousand revoked
certificates,
and so that would take 1.1
megabytes, but actually,
the list changes very slowly,
so you can just publish diffs,
and the whole thing is
only 40 kilobytes per day.
So, this is an example of
data-driven system design,
what's out there, how
can we exploit it.
Now, I want to say a little bit
about Machine Learning.
The application of
Machine Learning
in computer networking is old.
So, here's a paper from
a survey from 2008 that's
been cited a thousand times,
Traffic classification.
This is a thing people
have done for a long time.
Trying to figure out,
is this an attack?
What kind of application
is running here?
This is an old application.
I was thinking a little bit
about places where you
might use Machine Learning in
the context of
content delivery networks.
So, one of the things
that Akamai tries to do,
is predict for each client
on the internet,
a billion clients,
which of our servers would
give best performance.
This is an example where you
have multiple datasets
of different character,
you have past performance,
you have network measurements,
you have network
topology information,
you're trying to
make a prediction,
and here you could try
to use Machine Learning.
Another application is
trying to figure out,
is this a legitimate client?
We have a lot of
trouble with botnets
trying to break into
banking customers.
So, we want to develop
a reputation for a client,
or estimate the physical
location of a client.
This is easy if
there's some way for
a client to click on
the "Allow" button
to give up their location?
But Akamai doesn't
touch clients the
same way that say
a content provider does.
These kinds of things work best
when the penalty for
false positives is low.
So, it's okay if whatever
algorithm you're
using does poorly,
as long as it doesn't
hurt that much when you
make the wrong decision.
So, when we decide
a client is suspicious,
we don't ban it, but
we rate limit it.
Or, if we decided a participant
in our peer to peer
content delivery system,
Akamai has tens of
millions of clients in
a system that does
this is suspicious,
we just kick it out and say,
"You have to download
from the CDN."
Okay, I'll finish there.
>> Any quick questions?
>> [inaudible] kind
of like trying to
say data-driven and
machine learning
is a good thing for networking,
but I see there's
something different
between you and says
the first talk is not
talking about the catalyst
of success of
machine learning networking is
because we have more expensive,
more complex models like
Neural Network as an example.
But you're not talking about
a catalyst is because we had
most all of a sudden
we have more data.
Right? We have
more data from Occam or
we had data from Google
and it's kind of
explosion of more of data
that is the kind of
a driving force behind this.
So, is it true that
you think having
more data is kind of more
important to have
a more complex model?
>> Okay. So, I'm not right,
that was exactly the
point I wanted to
make but I do like the way you
summarized it that
the fact that we have more
data is giving us
new opportunities,
new ways of designing systems and
perhaps ML is a tool that
can be used to help do that.
>> That's a good point
for follow up as well and
abandoned more data
or model complexity.
>> Next up we have David Moitz
who's a distinguished
engineer at Microsoft.
He leads Azure's Physical
Networking Team.
His team builds the software and
network devices that connects
Microsoft largest
services including
the Azure public cloud
and being prior to that,
David was at Microsoft autopilot
and then before that he had
spent five years at M Assad.
David has won the sitcom test of
time award as well as
the ECM system software.
>> Great thanks guys.
So, I'm here talking
about the work of the Azure
Physical Networking Team.
We're called the
Physical Networking Team
because you might
imagine we're in
charge of actually
getting packets between
all the servers inside
of our data centers.
I want to talk to you
a little bit about
the environment in which we work.
So, we're building
a really large network.
Hundreds of thousands links
of each data center,
hundreds of data centers
around the world.
You know when you talk about
large scale large data sets,
the network is very good at
generating those kinds of things.
And just to be clear,
the number one job for
my team is high availability.
Is making sure that
every packet that gets
sent by every server is
running in our network
actually makes it
across that network and
received appropriately by
the destination servers.
And the challenge we have is
that at this large scale,
the law large numbers
is not your friend.
Yes we see lots of
nice median behavior,
but it turns out
nobody cares about
what happens at
the 50th percentile.
People who care about
what happened at
the strange edge conditions,
what is the very high
nine's percentile
of your behavior of packet
loss and everything else?
So, instead of Occam's Razor,
where the simplest explanation
is the most likely,
you get Murphy's Law.
There is something crazy
happening in some
part of the network.
There's going to generate
really weird behavior and
my team's job is to go
figure out what that
is and stop it.
So, we take a network this
is actually sort of a shot
of a rendering of
one small part of our network
in one small data center,
you can see all the
inter connectivity
and go find that proverbial
needle in a haystack.
Sadly we're actually
pretty good at it,
but sadly it does often take
us quite a bit of time.
Again the time to mitigate
these problems is also
very important because
our customers are suffering.
They are bleeding
money reputation and
everything while we go and
try and find these
problems and resolve them.
So, how can machine
learning help us with this?
So, I'm going to have
sort of a mixed message.
I'm going to show you a couple of
problems where I
think ML probably
has some things to offer
us and we've been
getting some benefits.
I'm not trying to characterize
some things where
ML is probably not
the best approach
and I hope I have enough time
to end with a little bit of
commentary about from
a practitioner's guide,
if you're a normal person
and want to work with
system scientists or
research scientists,
you want to work with ML people,
how can you cross the knowledge
gap between those two?
I'll talk about sort of the three
examples and I'll come back to
sort the commentary text on
the side as we go through.
Let me start with
a problem called
Layer One Topology Generation.
So, the basic problem
here is we want to keep
our network from failing.
We want to keeps
our optical network from failing
from various data centers
or regions that are
network being partition from
the rest of the network
due to fiber cuts
rather fiber failures.
Now, you're like, hey guys
this is an easy problem.
You tell me the availability
distributions time between
failure time to repair
for your fiber and we can
predict what the availability
what any particular
region should be.
The problem is the following.
Fiber providers( a) don't
really know this information
and (b) innovative they
did they're going to lie
and they're not really
going to give us someone
who's trying to
acquire fiber to build
our network accurate information.
So the question is, given
the fact that we have to acquire
new fiber paths all the time to
continue to build and
extend our network,
we need to acquire
enough fiber paths in
the right kinds of fiber paths to
the availability
targets that we want,
how can we actually predict
what this time between
failure and time to repair
distributions are going to
be for a new fiber path?
Now, we have a large bunch
of fiber pass already
in our inventory.
So, if we could take
our experience that we've
actually measured from
existing fiber paths
and figure out how to
apply that to estimate the
characteristics for new fiber,
we could do a pretty good job.
Challenge here is
there are lots and
lots and lots of
relevant dimensions.
There's where the fiber goes,
there's how many construction
sites it goes through,
there's how many people
live along that fiber,
there's how many kilometers
are aerial fiber,
how many kilometers
are buried fiber.
Lots and lots of other variables
that can be extracted
for each of these paths.
Unfortunately, we don't
want topology decisions
or fiber path selection decisions
to be made based
on human emotion.
There's oh, we bought
some fiber from
this company last time and
they really were nice to us.
We like them so we
should buy more fiber
from them or I know
this person who worked
on that project
and they're very
reputable so let's buy.
Right? That's not the right
approach to this.
So, we've actually had
some pretty good initial results
in sort of this
overall problem space.
This is data from
not exactly the problem
I just described,
but a very related
one of trying to
estimate what the availability
of particular portions
of our topology is
going to be based
on our estimated and
then simulated data,
versus the actual availability.
So, the green bars
represent our actual
observed availability,
the blue is the average of
our simulated an estimated
availability and you
can see in some cases we
undershoot in some
cases we overshoot.
We're doing a lot better
than random chance here.
So, again that gives us hope
that this is the kind of
thing where classification
algorithms can
extract dimensionality
that's not obvious to
a human being that is still
going to give us
good business value.
Is this ML, is a statistics,
should we be using PCA or
other kinds of
straight stats versus
more harder to explain
classification algorithms?
That's really interesting
conversation to have
me we'll talk about
during the panel.
Another problem, optical
performance optimization.
So, we have what we
call Open Line Systems.
Microsoft has
actually been one of
the companies out there
driving towards this.
Rather than buying a highly
integrated system from one of
the standard optical
vendors where
you have to buy all the
equipment from them,
we're trying to get to
a desegregated ecosystem
where you can buy line systems
and amplifiers from
one company transponders from
another and mix it
or match together.
One of the reasons is
because these systems,
when you open them up,
actually have lots
of parameters that
we can tune to maximize
the number of bits per
second that can actually be
delivered across
any individual piece of glass.
These are things
like the transmit
power, the received power,
how many amplifiers you
put along your path,
all of this kind of stuff.
Is this a good machine
learning problem?
Okay, we've got a bunch of
parameters and we want to
set them appropriately.
This is a control system,
a problem in any one's sense.
I'm going to argue,
no. This isn't.
Why? Availabilities is are
job number one, right?
So, I can actually tolerate
many of the errors that a
machine learning system
might put into
the misclassification
or misestimation
of the parameters.
Two, I have a really good set.
I have a physics textbook
that more or less
describes exactly the
plant model of how
this optical line system
and all the amplifiers in
power generation and
noise perturbations
is going to work.
So, I can use much more
standard control theory,
because I have that forward
plant model to say,
"If I use this set of parameters,
what's actually going to happen,
what's going to
happen my signal?"
And I can then spin that loop
as often and only when
needed to try and tune
the system, okay?
If you've got to something where
the physical layer
is well understood,
I don't quite see
what we're going to
use ML to try and do this,
even though I do see a lot of
people out there trying to use
ML kinds of approaches to
this sort of a problem.
Third problem,
network availability.
Hopefully, by now, you can
see where the thinking is.
Essentially, if you've
got a really big dataset,
you've got the potential for
machine learning problem.
If what's underlying
that big dataset is
a bunch of physical layers or
properties that are
well understood,
you understand the interactions
between all the variables,
you're probably better off
using standard control theory and
some forward plant model
to drive your system.
If you're in a world
where you don't even know
which of these variables
are actually
salient and most important,
you don't know which
ones are going to be
most descriptive in
predicting the outcome,
that's where a bunch
of machine learning types
of algorithms can come
up and actually help the surface
a much better model than
any human being is
going to come up with.
Let's look at this last one,
network availability.
So, again, let's talk
about preventing failures.
Now, it turns out
when you have a big
complicated network like this,
I have lots of redundant paths.
If any device or a link fails and
actually shuts itself
off when it fails,
I am totally fine.
The problem we have is what
we call Gray switch failures,
where some piece of
equipment actually starts
dropping some small fraction
of the packets that
go through it,
but not enough that
it actually fail to
stops and takes itself
out of service.
When it stays in service
while dropping packets,
now that's a problem
my team has to go
through and find the device
and shut it down,
and there's going
to be customer pain
and impact until we do so.
This really is the needle
in a haystack problem.
Again, we have lots of
different data sources.
In part, because
we've tried many,
many different approaches
to this problem.
So, for example, we've
set a Pingmeshes.
We have all of our servers
sending ping packets through
the network and we're measuring
latency and failure rates.
We have targeted probe systems,
which are actually sending
different types of
probe packets of
different kinds to try
and simulate different behaviors,
and we can target more probes
on the links that we
think might be dropping packets,
we've got error messages,
basically debugging pirnits
that are coming back from
the switches that may or may not
indicate a problem on
the switches themselves.
We've got these end-to-end
service health metrics,
all the services running
across the network
which are telling us,
"I'm happy, I'm not happy,
I'm getting worse,
I'm getting better."
Essentially, the problem
we now have is,
how do we combine
all these things
to localize the problem?
We have a whole bunch
of noise coming out of
the best classification
and recognition systems
that we were able to
build individually.
So, this is now one of
those metal level things.
One set of technology for
this would be boosting.
How can we use boosting is
a way to pull more signal out
of the noise being
generated by each of
these other smaller
classification systems.
We've also use
stochastic gradient descent
and other kinds of algorithms,
in a fault propagation model,
to try and work
backwards to what is
the most likely explanation
for this set of symptoms that
we're currently observing.
But this, again, is a really
rich and important area,
and something where, again,
we have these large datasets.
And sometimes they're
pretty well labeled,
we know whether the services
are healthier or not.
Coming back to that final point
about Practitioner's Guide.
I'm not a machine
learning person.
I am a networking researcher
as well at heart,
and the thing I've seen the most
is what we call
the Knowledge Gap.
There are some people who
know machine-learning,
know the algorithms there
really, really well.
I've got a bunch of
network scientists who
know how A6 work and how A6 fail,
and how to look at service data.
The problem we have is when
people are more interested
in their own field than they
are at solving the problem,
these people can't
talk to each other,
or they just fail to
talk to each other.
So, for data science,
the people who want to come
work with systems people,
I think the key thing is having
to become more interested in
solving the problem and
learning more about
the specific subject material,
then in even knowing in
the classification algorithms in
order to make forward progress,
to basically establish
what are the metrics,
what are the salient dimensions,
to be able to work through
the data and sort through it,
to come up with better outcomes.
I've experienced some
positive examples of this.
I've experienced some negative
examples of this,
and I'm glad to be part of
the conversation here and
talk more. So, thank you.
>> Okay, questions? Okay,
next up we have Keith.
Keith is from Stanford,
where he is an
Assistant Professor.
His research is in
Network Systems and it mostly
cuts across traditional
abstraction boundaries
and uses statistical techniques.
Keith has won the second
dissertation award.
Prior to being a professor,
he was a staff reporter at
the Wall Street Journal.
He later worked at Ksplice,
which was acquired by
Oracle where he was
the Vice President of
Product Management
and Business Development,
and according to his webpage,
he was also responsible
for cleaning the bathroom.
Yes. Welcome, Keith.
>> Thank you. I don't
know which input I'm
on. I think he's working on it.
Perfect. All right,
thank you very much.
I'm not an expert in anything,
but I was invited
to be on this panel
so I'm going to do my best.
I think I'm going
to do with biology,
machine learning is good.
One thing I want to highlight is
that when people say
machine learning,
they mean a bunch of
different things.
I think there are maybe,
at least three paradigms in
which we talk about using
machine learning
in the context of
deploying an operational system.
So, Paradigm 1 is what I'll
call learn then deploy.
So you learn something,
machine-learning
produces an artifact,
someone runs in a data center
on a million core GPU,
all kinds of stuff, we
produce an awesome artifact,
learned the network and then
we deploy that network.
That's Paradigm 1. Paradigm 2,
it's about learning in real life.
We deploy something and
then we learn over time.
Something's in
the field, we learn.
Paradigm 3, I'm going to call,
we learn from the machines.
Not the computer learning,
but machine-learning
teaches us about
our own thinking.
Like these are
sort of three different ways
we could talk about
machine learning in the context
of network systems.
I guess I have sort of
three different views.
Paradigm 1, which I
think is currently
the dominant one
people talk about.
In my opinion, it's often
harder than we expect,
that's not obvious but
it's often tricky.
Paradigm 2, this
deploy and learn.
They continuously
learning in the field.
I think is quite valuable and I
think we should research it,
but it's hard because of
the nature of network systems.
I think there's other domains
where this is probably easier,
but in networks is not so easy.
I think we should be
working on those problems.
Paradigm 3, this idea that we
can learn from the experience
of teaching a machine to
match us in some capability,
I am not such old-fashioned,
like 1960s view, but I think
it's still true today.
I think we should talk
more in this term.
So, I'm going try and talk
about it in that sense.
So, Paradigm 1,
learn then deploy.
Why do I say it's often
harder than we expect?
Well, I have been bit by this.
So, here's a paper
for me that was
NSDI 2013 about
a machine-learning
congestion control algorithm,
uses Bayesian reasoning for
congestion control,
the sprout algorithm.
You can see on this graph,
the best algorithms have
the lowest delay and
the best throughput.
So, the best algorithms
are all algorithm,
sprout up into the right,
we're very proud of that.
Now, what happens in real life?
So we deploy this around
the world, and five years later,
here's the result that was taken
yesterday on the T-Mobile
network in California.
Same kind of graph.
Here's sprout.
So, still sort of
up into the right,
but it's not really
as dominant as we
showed in our paper
from five years ago.
There's a whole bunch of
other algorithms that are on
this Pareto frontier,
that's in America.
This is the same place we
measured when we did our paper.
Here's result that was literally
this morning in New Delhi,
India on the Airtel network.
Here's my algorithm, it
is terrible, it sucks.
Can I say that here?
I don't know where,
okay, thank you.
So, Yes this learn
then deploy I learned,
I wrote a paper about it,
the paper won an award,
I got a professorship.
Now, we learned in the field
that doesn't actually work,
at least not outside America.
This is not a good paradigm
for anyone other than me,
I'm the beneficiary,
but not everyone else.
So, that's my algorithm.
Here's a different
algorithm Vivace,
and this was published
in NSDI 2018.
Here's the publication again.
We see really good
performance here which
shares the link is
flows enter and leave.
This is in the paper.
Here's the result,
again, this morning in Brazil.
Same algorithm but again
it's quite different
from the paper.
We see that the first
flow dominates,
the second flow much less,
the third flow much less.
So, there's the difference
again between
the learn and then the deploy.
Here's a different paper,
this is the pensive paper
that was at SIGCOMM, the
most recent SIGCOMM.
This is a learned
scheme for deciding
which video bit rate to
send a user over a network,
where there's unpredictability
about the network,
and whether they're
going to need to
re-buffer and you want to
have good quality video
but you don't want to
run out of buffer,
so this is in the paper,
if you take the same
learned artifact,
and you deploy it
over similar networks
some students in my class tried
and they got these results.
So, again that learn it
works when you learn it,
but later when you deploy
it, something's different.
It doesn't work anymore.
The only way to know
this is to teach
a networking class where
you can compel students
to reproduce papers, and
then they have to do it.
It's not actually easy to
learn this information.
We put a lot of
effort into deploying
this global infrastructure
whose conclusion
is that I was wrong,
but if we hadn't done that we
would never know I would be
going around blissfully
talking about how great I was.
Here's another one, so BBR
this is an algorithm from Google,
this was published in ACM Queue,
and they say BBR converges
towards a fair share of
the bottleneck bandwidth,
and worst-case,
the oppositional algorithms might
grab more than their fair share.
BBR can have less
than its fair share.
That's the claim in the paper,
here is a slide
presentation from ripe
76 just a few months ago,
and the gentleman from APNIC
finds that's just not true.
Here's a cubic flow and
suddenly when
the BBR flow starts,
it crushes the cubic flow.
So, there's learn,
Google learned it,
but then when you deploy it, you
get something quite different.
So, what they find is that BBR is
not a scalable approach,
it works great when
just a few users use it
like one big company,
but not when lots
of people use it,
is BBR a failure,
not necessarily because now
there's going to be a BBR
2.0, we'll see what happens.
Here's another example.
So, network system a
broad field let's talk
what search engines.
There's a lot of interest
in using the data
from search engines to learn
things about the real world.
In 2008, Google had a paper
about learning about the flu,
from the search queries
that they got.
The idea here is to learn,
a model to predict
the real-world flu incidence by
correlating search engine queries
against government flu data.
Which is released on
two to three week time lag.
They learn the model,
and then they deployed in
real-time to break flu in
advance of the government to help
direct vaccines more efficiently.
So, this was on the front page of
The New York Times,
aches, a sneeze,
a Google search, it was a nature,
that was on Charlie Rose,
and Google put this plot
on their website,
and you can see the predictor
which is in blue
does really good,
against the real life data
which is in yellow.
This is what they put
on their website,
they don't show you is this,
it's actually the vast majority
this plot is training data.
So, this is what it
is but it's actually
only a tiny bit of here
it was not trained on.
So this is hard so
they learned it
on this training data here,
I annotated the figure,
but then when they
actually deploy it,
this is not deployment.
It's they call it
historical estimates,
but it wasn't deployed
historically,
when they actually deploy,
this is what happens.
It goes crazy.
We don't know why, Google
eventually they kept
trying to fix this and
kept screwing up they
eventually gave up on it.
We don't know why this happens,
maybe someone in
the audience knows
why, I don't know why.
Here's another example,
Spam Filtering,
and then another sort of broadly
construed network
systems problems.
SpamAssasins is a spam
filtering engine,
has very clever
community approach,
the idea is that
anyone can propose
a spam filtering decision rule.
It's okay because a central party
learns the best weights
for each of these rules,
a sort of a panel of experts.
So, anyone can contribute
a putative expert.
People learn, essentially
they learn the best rates.
So, if you're expert is nonsense
they'll just give it
a weight of zero.
If it happens to be very
predictive they'll give
it a strong weight.
Those weights are then,
deployed in the field.
So, in 2007 people
proposed various rules,
some a rule, and the rule was,
does the year matched to 200 and
then any character, the date.
It turned out that
caught a lot of spam,
because a lot of spam is sent
for a date in the future.
Like a date like 2012,
which would happen
in the future so
that would've been spam.
So, this had an extremely low
false positive rate
when they learned it.
People can see why,
because it is in
2007 that they're learning
it? So, what happened?
January 1st, 2010 SpamAssassin
started killing
every message spam.
Physicists are very easy
to see case where did they
learn then deployed it just
falls down in the real world.
Because they had this idea
that the algorithms
were black boxes,
they didn't have to
know how they worked,
they just looked at empirically
how well they worked,
and they waited them according
to real performance,
that did not work
when time evolved.
Time is a very clear case here
if you depend on the date.
As soon as you hit 2010
times is going to evolve.
So, what was the fix for this?
How do you fix this problem?
>> You got change dates?
>> What was that?
>> Well, they just
changed it to 2020.
That's their new decision rule.
Yes. So, I think
the lesson here is
that it is very easy
to fool yourself,
and I think Feynman
says, "You are
the easiest person to fool".
This learn and deploy it is as
a challenging parrot pattern,
and empirically,
very very smart people,
and very very smart
mega corporations
embarrass themselves
going on television to,
in a segue with premature
declarations to success.
So, I think we have
to keep that in mind.
So, paradigm two is okay let's
deploy and learn over time.
We'll build systems that
learn continuously,
and we'll directly observe
the operational figure
of merit over time.
That way we can react quickly
to real-world changes.
The real-world changes
just we just change.
So, some people are
really good at this.
So, here's a paper from Google,
that quick paper at
SIGCOMM last year,
we see Google directly
observed everyday how
well quick is doing,
and if there's a problem,
they can immediately fix it.
Whether it's automatic,
or them they can fix it.
This is really a world that
I would want to live in.
It would be very comfortable
with deploying something
crazy because you can see
immediately how well it's doing.
Not just congestion control but,
in the real world we
do learn over time,
if I'm driving a car,
and something bad happens to me,
I'm going to learn,
I'm going to say,
"Wow, I'm definitely not going to
get that close to
a Ferrari next time".
You want to learn over time,
you don't want to just
have a fixed mindset
and do it continuously,
if you build a robot
to change a diaper,
and the baby wiggles out of it,
you want to learn
from that experience,
you don't want to be like,"Okay,
I'm going to stay fixed".
So, this continuous learning has
some intuitive appeal,
but it's hard.
It's hard on a network.
There's some classic results
that make it hard in
cases where information
is distributed.
So, learning is it's
much easier when
all the information
comes to one place,
when information is distributed,
it's really hard and
there's some old results,
that are therefore profound that
say that "In some cases
it's actually impossible".
Impossibilities based group
decision-making with
separate aggregation
of beliefs and values.
So,if you keep
the information apart,
It's really hard to learn
something consistent.
If you bring all
the information in one place,
you can do it.
If you're keeping
information apart, which
is what we'd like
to do on a network,
we like to be decentralized,
It's hard to do.
So, also have agents
are adversarial it's very
hard to handle this,
how do you handle
competing agents,
one guy says, "Oh,
I've learned this as best,
I learned this is best".
These are hard problems. They
are hard network problems.
They are problems
we should work on,
but they're not easy.
Michael Shapiro and I
actually have
a conjecture that it's
impossible for a decentralized
congestion control scheme
that greedily optimizing
an objective function
to be globally
asymptotically stable.
That it's an unproved conjecture,
but it may be hard in
these adversarial cases.
How about in neural networks?
Do we have to just
bring all the data to
the Cloud and learn there,
or just learning the edge?
It wouldn't it be nice my student
John Evans is working
on this project,
if the data in the computer
or in different places,
to still be able to learn
without having to bring
all the compute to the edge
or all the data in the Cloud.
It'll be nice to now split
the problem somehow,
and even learn continuously
between date and
the edge and computing the Cloud
and learn between them.
Unfortunately, so
far you can't do it.
There's a green region we
want to be in and
we're not in there.
So, lesson two is
deploy-and-learn can be great,
but it's hard on a network,
when data's in different places,
computes in different places,
and people are adversarial.
So, I think to wrap up I think
I'm most excited about is
this old fashioned view that
the real benefit of teaching
something to a machine,
is that you learn about
that thing yourself.
We can tell the machine
design a system,
and the machine comes, here
my requirements, here my goals,
machine comes back and
says, "How about this",
it's better if it looks so weird,
if we think that's crazy,
but huh, it does meet
the requirements,
and it does maximize
the objective,
that's very interesting let
me clarify my thinking,
that "Hmm" is like the most
exciting thing in science.
So, teaching something is
the best way to learn anything,
the dumber the student the
better the teacher will learn,
because if you explained
yourself so clearly,
machines are very dumb.
So, teaching machines to
learn to design systems
is the best way
for us to learn about what it
really means and what
we really care about.
So, to wrap up here,
I think Paradigm one,
it gets a lot of hype but it
is harder than we expect,
and it is so easy
to fool yourself.
Paradigm two, I think we
should be working on,
I certainly I'm working on it,
but the problems of
network systems,
the decentralization of data
and compute makes it hard.
And Paradigm three, I'm
quite sympathetic to,
and I think even
if we never deploy
anything that's the product
of Machine Learning,
we should still do
Machine Learning
because we learned so
much about the problem.
>> So, we had a set of
really interesting
perspectives on
the topic of this panel.
I'd like to thank
all the speakers.
I think what I heard
was for problems of
an inference nature,
I think Baraj you
talked about this,
and I think Dave you
also talked about it.
But we are trying to figure
out where the fault is in
the network and things like that.
It's obviously something that
lends itself well to
machine learning.
I think those who talked
about using data broadly,
and Kate you had
very interesting perspectives on
different styles of
applying machine learning.
I'd like to just start off with
a question and then we'll open
the floor for the audience
to ask questions.
I think networking people,
by training, are sort of
like to be predictable.
The RFC specify
what protocols must
do and if it's not a must
it's at least assured.
If such a message comes
this is what you should do.
If there's a packet lost
this is what you
should do and so on.
So, is there a cultural issue
in adapting to a world
where you don't have
that predictability
around the data
and the algorithm that
you don't understand
tells you something and you want
to make decisions based on that?
So, do you think there
is a inherent tension
there and sort of there's
a little hump that people need
to cross to get
comfortable applying
machine learning for what
critical networking decisions?
>> So, I mean,
the examples I talked about,
they are well-known actual
algorithms that do the job,
LASSO music and physics guys,
I was saying there may be some,
for example in
the networking case,
the new network
doesn't need to know
the adjacency matrix
because it's just a map.
It's a signal.
That's an advantage.
It doesn't need to
know the nature
of the noise. It's
going to learn.
So, I think it's
mostly that there's
certain factors that function
as learnable that
really is most of
the work goes in
establishing that fact and then
you trying using a neural
network to learn that function.
In the case of music, it
wasn't straightforward.
You really had to
work quite hard.
So, often shelf stuff
doesn't work.
But it wasn't much doubt
that function is
learnable because we know what
the function is and it's
got continuous parts
and lends itself just
visually into learnable.
So, I think that's one thing
about this question of
whether do you want data models,
the way you train these models
frankly is you need data
just to begin with.
Much of what we did or anybody's
doing it just requires it.
Whenever you're trying to
learn a function y equals
f of x, in a lot of it X,
I, Y pairs, then the function
has to be learnable.
So, that's really what I've seen.
There may be some cases
where the function
has some very bad sort of
Lipschitz continuity
properties then it may
be difficult to learn those bits,
but otherwise so far
it's pretty decent.
>> I can give you
function approximation example.
But I was asking
the question more broadly
about making
networking decisions.
>> Yes, I understand.
>> So, I heard the question
as one of, geez,
if I have a system
that I don't know
exactly how it works,
how do I have confidence
that I could actually take
action based on
its recommendations
and not make things worse.
And you'll all go
back to the adage.
People have a tendency
to screw things up but
to really make a big mess
it takes a computer.
So, I am trying to hook up
essentially machine
learning classification
systems that are looking at data
to automatic mitigation
mechanisms that will
go in and change our network
to try and fix problems.
That means is that if
that system runs a
mock you could actually go
create a much bigger problem
for our customers
than what actually
existed there organically
in the network.
So, for us it's been
this combination of guardrails.
Around the behavior of this
feedback loop essentially
so that no matter
what the classifier says it
thinks it should turn off
in order to maybe get a problem.
Remember that grid
failure example?
If I can find the switch
I think is bad,
I turn it off,
everything gets good.
But if I turn off
all the switches, that's bad.
So putting guardrails
around us we don't get
kind of runaway behavior
and that if it looks
like things are getting worse
and worse then we apply
the brakes to the system
and actually start
rolling back some of
the changes that we made.
In my domain, at least,
we have the ability
to sort of create
a closed feedback loop and
that's how we've approached it.
Certainly our system
is recommended
things to us that made
no sense and sometimes
there's right, sometimes
there's wrong.
>> But one of the things I like
about Dave's adage to error is
human but to really foul
things up it requires
a computer is that it
comes from the 1970's.
They already knew back then.
But when you talk about concerns
about whether we have
a system whose behavior we
don't really understand,
I got to tell you
you're deluded if you
think we understand
how the systems
we've been building work.
Okay. We already don't
understand them.
It's just a question of degree.
>> I think it's
a question of illusion.
That is, we thought we're
the students so that
we felt comfortable.
>> But going back a little bit to
the specifics of your question,
there's this cultural question
like "Do network
engineers want to
give up control to something
they don't understand
by a machine?"
But on the other hand
if you actually
look at RFCs that say
should and would,
that kind of provides
the framework and the
more of that that's in
the RFC probably the better off
you are because it says
your learning algorithm,
it's only going to
have a few knobs
that can change and you have
some hope you're going
to understand it.
So, that goes both ways.
>> I think it's also
this composition.
You can probably understand
something at a single level.
It's like when you
have packets here and
then there's protocols that
are driving these packets
and then they rely on
the arrival of acknowledgements
and that doesn't happen.
Now, something at
this level triggers
something at one level above
that trigger something.
It's almost like a f of g of h
of k sort of composing now.
You only see the first thing and
the last thing and you don't
know where it's breaking.
That sort of stuff
is really hard.
You can't isolate the fault very
easily and that's what
frustrates us networking folks.
We design with understanding
but unfortunately we
compose things now and they
become big and complex.
>> I think there's sort of
a sense where if something has
only a small number of parameters
we thought that we understood it.
Take the AI MD algorithm in TCP.
You added an increase by
one, divide it by two.
There's two parameters and
we wrote some nice proofs.
And to then discover that
actually the flock behavior of
a decentralized network
of computers running TCP,
even with those
two parameters, is
incredibly complicated.
Has all kinds of fun
things that we discovered.
It's actually
chaotic overdraft TLQ,
and there's problems like
incast but have to
do with the sort
of packet by packet behavior
that don't show up
in fluid models.
So, even something with
just two parameters when run in
a decentralized
networks situation
is so fun but also so buggy.
That's a sort of fun and
also humbling discovery.
I think there's an appropriate
caution about deploying
something with a 100 million
learn parameters.
If we can't even get the AI and
the MD understand those dynamics,
I think we should
be appropriately
humble about our ability
to reason about a system
with a million parameters.
Doing machine learning to
optimize tail behavior or
worst-case behavior
especially in the presence
of adversarial input is
an unsolved problem.
It's one thing to optimize
average-case behavior of an
image recognition program.
And we know that
adversarial input
to in image recognition
is actually the adversary
has the better hand there.
You can change
one pixel and suddenly
a puppy turns into
the Sears Tower.
So, I think there's
an appropriate caution about
increasing the number
of parameters.
Defining a guardrail, which I
think is such a good point,
I don't think we
know how to define
the guardrails for
many decentralized scenarios.
I mean, how do you
define stability?
How do you define
a guardrail when you
only observe part
of the situation?
These are fun problems that we
should be working on but I
don't think we have the answers.
>> Right. I think
an interesting question
is whether adversarial attacks
become more likely or less likely
with machine learning system
versus a hand crafted system.
But I think let's hold
onto that question.
I'd like to open
the floor for questions
from the audience.
Yes. Do we have
microphones? Okay.
>> Thanks. Is this on?
Okay. Tensor really has
interesting set of talks.
My question is sort of more
broadly about the use of
training datasets for
machine learning
which is fundamental.
Obvious problem with
such training datasets
is that rare events are
by definition rare,
and the kind of control systems
that we need to put into
place for dealing with
such events are not going to be
perhaps even available
in the training dataset.
So, there's
critical dependency on
the training dataset and
the fact that
these datasets may not
include the cases that
you care about in
practice makes reliance on
machine learning only as
your control system probably bad.
>> I think that's a fair point.
So, the kinds of
things that are in
my examples that we're
trying to learn do
actually happen a couple of
times a day across the fleet.
So, they're rare but they
happen often enough
that we actually have
positive examples
and we can define
a false-positive
false-negative rate on it.
I still have to have
human engineers on call
24/7 365 because
things will break
that has never been
seen before and
that any of the automatic
classification systems
just don't know what to do with.
Then we're back to
good old human troubleshooting.
I mean, we talked with the ideas
of trying to actually inject.
When we have a partial
forward plant model
and can predict if
this thing broke,
what would it look like in
terms of the symptoms we observe,
trying to reject more essentially
synthetic failures into
our training data, mixed success.
>> Any other questions?
>> I guess a question maybe
following up on Keath's talk.
Do you think there's
a prospect for designing
systems to be machine learnable?
>> Yes.
>> And tell us how.
>> Oh.
>> I mean,
>> Okay. Low systems
without a lot of
high frequency response
are much easier to
train a system for than
ones that are very twitchy.
So, I think stability,
slow evolution, and
behavior over time.
Good network architecture,
good system architecture,
whether you're trying to have
humans understand what's
going on or an AI system
understand what's going on,
they're all easier to control.
>> We've understood
for a long time how to
build congestion
control protocols
that don't need machine
learning to operate well.
We just don't build
those systems.
For whatever reason, we
use more complicated
mechanisms for
coordination than we
really needed to just
because man invented an algorithm
that we all have
to live with now.
So, there is
this question, I think,
of if we have designed
for testability
or modular design for
agility or whatever,
do we need a set of
design principles
for telling engineers how
to build systems that can
actually be predictable?
>> Sure. I think,
they involve taking away the
things that make
the problem hard.
So, get rid of decentralization,
get rid of adversaries,
the problem becomes much easier.
So, I can just control scheme
where there is a central
dictator that governs
the allocation of
everybody is much easier
to reason about than
a Van Jacobson style scheme
where there's a partially
deliverable markup
decision process
that's solved in
decentralize fashion.
That is literally
an undecidable problem
in general in computer science.
So, that's why congestion control
is so hard if you
do it decentralize.
If you bring all
the information in
one place and have a dictator
make the decision,
it becomes much easier.
>> But maybe observation is that
there are many of
these kinds of tassels.
For another one, it's
not centralization,
decentralize but time to
convergence or efficiency
and optimality.
Sometimes giving up on some of
those dimensions can actually
get your system
that's going to be
far easier to understand
or far simpler.
But it is a trade-off.
>> I agree.
So, maybe there's
an intuitive feeling that the
more you squeeze the
optimization level in one place,
all the other things
are going to get worse.
So, if you squeeze for
great average-case performance,
probably your tails
and your liability
and your adversary robustness,
adversary in form of loosener
are going to get worse.
So, maybe if we stop squeezing
for the thing that gets
you promoted, then
we'll all be happier.
I mean, being less glib.
Maybe if we somehow
value these harder to define
metrics instead of just your
average-case performance or
95th percentile performance and
stop squeezing so
hard on that one,
maybe understandability
and stability,
if we can quantify those,
we might be able to
optimize for those instead.
>> Also, the world of algorithms,
there's better chance
to subsystems.
There's more chance of this
being very helpful just
because it's very clean and it
got easier definition of what.
If this input arrives,
I want this desirable output.
I think there you
can see success.
>> It used to be one
of the requirements is
good telemetry system
that actually gives you
the data that you need
from actual deployment.
I think search engines did
a great job because they
had all the data and so we know
exactly what it is that
we're clicking on and so on.
Whereas, networking
systems, I don't think
a lot of data comes
back because it's all
over the place and it's
expensive to bring it back.
So, I think that's the challenge.
I think we have
just a couple more minutes,
so I want to ask
a final question.
>> I think it's fair to say
that overall the whole
systems and networking
community has
a cautionary approach to
infusing ML into the whole mix.
It's fair. A lot of
reasons were brought up
in all the presentations,
we can outline that as well.
My question to the panelists is,
do you see any
sub-areas of systems
and networking where we would
actually be better off if
we lower the caution bar,
and then the systems could
evolve faster and for the better.
I understand it's not
all the sub-areas but
any specific sub-areas
you could think of?
>> How about the scheduler or
the branch predictor?
Those kinds of things.
>> Why is it do you
think that lowering
the caution bar in those is
better than say, condition?
>> I think those are
examples perhaps where
when there's a misprediction,
the cost isn't so high.
Now, David, he's worried
about individual
packets being lost.
That's not the right case
then, you might
not want to do it.
But if it's just a
question of, well,
it's just going to
cost us a little more
but we get the same performance
or it's a microscopic change
in performance,
you don't need to be as cautious.
That's the low-hanging fruit.
Especially, and you may
not need to know why
it made the decision
because if it's wrong,
it didn't cost you that much.
>> There's totally
no way that I couldn't
use quarks of our branch
prediction algorithm
and speculative execution to
steal information out of
a process or anything.
That would totally never work.
>> Yes.
I'm not sure it'd be worse if you
used a neural network, though.
I mean, how about
the query planner in a database?
I think these kinds of things,
we're already using sort
of folklore method,
so why not use a neural network?
>> Okay. I think
we need to close,
but I just want you to
take 30 seconds each.
Usually, we ask people
to predict the future,
but I'm going to change
the question here.
If you had that machine
learning technology and
horsepower that we have
today in the '80s,
when congestion control took
shape or in the '90s
when BGP was designed
or maybe the 2000s when
firewalls and deep packet
inspection and so on
came into the fold,
how would things have been
done differently that
would perhaps make
us better off today?
If you had to
redesign things with
machine learning technologies
available to you,
what would have happened
differently? Just quick.
>> Okay, I can go first. I'm just
using the example as music thing.
It learns the environment.
So you come out on
off-the-shelf with
an algorithm that works in
many environments fairly well
but not optimized for anything,
can be, and then you
deploy in a particular,
like in your indoor home area,
you got some VR headset.
That thing really
works differently in
the basement room or
which one each work.
I think that's an example
of something where
it's adaptive to the environment.
>> I think that if we'd had
this horsepower in the '80s,
I would've been able to say,
"Okay, Google, why is
the network so slow?"
It would say, "I'm sorry. I
can't help you with that."
That's the kind of
thing it's good at.
It's recognizing patterns.
It can understand my question,
but it doesn't know the answer.
>> Anyone else?
Congestion control.
>> Okay, fine.
The truth is that people
have been talking about
congestion control
in the context of machine
learning since it started.
I mean, Kashev's paper on
packet pair it talks about
the then prevailing paradigm
of machine learning,
which was fuzzy logic.
That's right, right?
Yes, I mean, it's all about
fuzzy logic which was
the upper hype thing
in the early '90s.
I bet if deep neural networks
have been around then,
you would have read
the exact same paper,
but you'd have subbed
out fuzzy logic for
neural networks but nothing would
change about the algorithm.
So, I don't know.
>> Okay. The last one.
>> Yes. I'm not really
coming up with one either.
The one thing I do
know is whenever
Skynet tries to take
over the world,
it will probably crash because
of a networking problem.
>> Okay. On that note, let's
thank our panel again.